what we're going to talk about in this
video are the origins of the russian
people and in particular we're going to
talk about the eastern slavs who
not just modern russians but also
ukrainians and bello russians view as
their ancestors
so let's think about the world in the
9th century
the early 9th century we see the reign
of charlemagne that we talk about in
some depth in other videos as we get
into the 10th century you see the reign
of otto the great holy roman emperor
over the germanic kingdoms
the 9th century is also the time of tang
china you have the abbasid muslim
caliphate in control over most of the
middle east and north africa
and it is also the viking age
so what we have here in this magenta
color this would be modern day sweden
but it was also the home of the
varangians or whom we later would refer
to as the vikings and we know them to be
great seafarers in western europe
they're viewed as raiders of towns along
the coast but you have to remember these
histories are often written by the
western europeans not by the vikings
themselves but they were also known as
traders
what you see here are two of the major
centers of power and trade in the 9th
century you have constantinople the
capital of the byzantine empire and you
have baghdad the capital of the abbasid
caliphate you also see these major
waterways in eastern europe in
particular the nipper and the volga
rivers and so you have these significant
trade routes going from the baltic sea
either via the nipper crossing the black
sea to constantinople or going from the
baltic to the volga all the way to the
caspian sea and eventually making their
way to baghdad
and this is well documented there is
archaeological evidence of viking
jewelry along these routes there's
evidence of artifacts from these far-off
lands in viking territory and we believe
what the varangians traded were furs
that they hunted in this area of
northern europe
now the people who lived in this area
were known as the slavs and there were
several broad groups of slavs that you
will hear historians refer to
you have the western slavs who you could
view as some of the ancestors of modern
poles czechs and slovaks
you have the southern slavs and what
would eventually be referred to as the
balkans and then you have the eastern
slavs in what will eventually be russia
belarus and ukraine now to be clear they
weren't unified groups there were many
many many for example eastern slavic
tribes
our best account of the early history
especially in the period as we get into
the 9th century comes from what is known
as the russian primary chronicle and
keep in mind this was written at a much
later period it was written in the early
12th century
it is sometimes ascribed to the kievan
monk nestor so previous times it was
known as nestor's chronicles but we
don't even have surviving accounts of
this we have surviving accounts of
copies of this or what we believe are
copies of this
what i'll share is a version of the
russian primary chronicle known as the
laurentian text from
1377 and this is an of course an english
translation it gives us some of the
earliest accounts of the relationship
between the varangians and the eastern
slavs and how what we have come to
identify as the russian people and the
ukrainian people and the belarusian
people how they got their start
so right before this passage it talks
about how the varangians tried to get
tribute from some of the eastern slavic
tribes
and it says the tributaries of the
varangians drove them back beyond the
sea and refusing them further tribute
set out to govern themselves so they
pushed them back beyond what we now call
the baltic sea and they decided to
govern themselves
there was no law among them tribe rose
against tribe and they began to war one
against another they said to themselves
let us seek a prince who may rule over
us and judge us according to the law
they accordingly went overseas to the
varangian ruses
so they went back to the ruses and they
said these these warring eastern slavic
tribes said our land is great and rich
but there is no order in it come to rule
and reign over us
they thus selected three brothers
the oldest rurik located himself in
novgorod
right over here novgorod literally means
new town gorad means town the district
of novgorod became known as the land of
rus
so a lot of really interesting things
going on
the viranjians first are trying to get
tribute from these tribes which is a way
of saying tax them making them
subservient to these vikings and even
though these eastern slavs were able to
push them back according to the primary
chronicle they said hey we need your
help we want you to rule over us there's
very few times in history where people
are asking a foreign group to rule over
them and so this is an interesting
question remember this history is
written under the rule of one of the
descendants of rurik so do you think it
was actually this way or do you think
the varangians maybe force themselves on
the eastern slavs and later created this
narrative that they were invited to come
in but according to the primary
chronicle we have rurik coming from
scandinavia to novgorod and establishing
the land of ruse
now the word ruse is really interesting
most historians believe it to be the
source of what we now say russia or even
belarus which means white ruse
some historians think it comes from the
name of sweden at the time
some believe that the ruse were a
subgroup of varanjians of vikings
some believe that the word is derived
from those who row
but either way the primary chronicle
goes on to tell us
from 870 to 879
on his deathbed rurik bequeathed his
realm to oleg who belonged to his kin
and entrusted to oleg's hands his son
igor for he was very young
and then from 880 to 882
oleg set himself up as prince in kiev
and declared that it should be the
mother of russian cities
so rurik's immediate successor is oleg
and in the early 80s he goes and
establishes himself in kiev expanding
the land of ruse
this is kiev right over here and because
oleg was able to take kiev
the state that emerges from rurik and
oleg not only is it known as the land of
the ruse but is often known as the
kievan state and they are often known as
the kievan rus
and you can see here how that state
expands over the next few hundred years
as we get to the year 900 you have this
off-white color and you can see it is in
control of both novgorod and kiev as you
get to 1015 it's taken even more
territory and by 1113 which is near the
peak of the kievan state you see that it
has taken control of a good chunk of
eastern europe and as the state expands
its character changes as well
as you get to the end of the 10th
century you have a major event in one of
rurik's descendants of vladimir often
known as vladimir the great he decides
to convert to eastern orthodox
christianity and in a future video i
might talk about his rationales or what
historians view as his rationales for
conversion and as we will see over time
and because of not only his conversion
but essentially the conversion of the
entire kievan state over time especially
with the eventual decline of the
byzantine empire what would eventually
be russia becomes a center of eastern
orthodox christianity
now the kievan state
lasts as an independent state until we
get to the 13th century
and for many other videos you might be
guessing what happens in the 13th
century
you have genghis khan and then his
descendants emerge out of eastern and
central asia
and in 1240 you have the mongol invasion
at which point many of the
principalities within the land of ruse
become tributaries to the mongolians and
they would be so for the next roughly
200 years until ivan the great comes
along and is able to exert independence
from the mongols for the ruse but we
will cover that in a future video